اهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه المستمره وشكرا
للزميل ابراهيم بدر اذا كما افاد مراسل
العربيه بان دمارا في عدد كبير من المباني
في البلدات القريبه من الحدود التركيه
شمال سوريا جوائز زلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
وتسبب في دماري حوالي 130 بنايه في ولايه
ملاطيا وفي حصيله اوليه اعلن عن سقوط 15
قتيلا على الاقل بما شدد وزير الداخليه
التركي على ان الوزراء سيتجهون الى
المناطق المتضرره لمواكبه عمليات الانقاذ
مؤكدا ان الاولويه هي للوصول الى
المحاصرين تحت الالقاب كما دعى مواطنه الى
الكف عن استخدام الهواتف المحموله
الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته
7.9 درجه جنوب تركيا ضرب في ساعه مبكره
تلك المناطق من صباح اليوم وشعر به سكان
قبرص ولبنان
وسوريا والعراق بالاضافه الى مصر
اذا كما ذكرنا بان عده دول محاذيه لتركيا
شعرت باثار هذا زلزال معنا من اربيل
الزميل احمد الحمداني اذا احمد قوه
الزلزال وصلت الى اربيل هل هناك اي ارقام
حتى الان او
ابلاغ عن وقوع دمار في المباني او اصابات
حتى الان
صباح الخير محمد طبعا اربيل وايضا محافظات
دهوك سليمانيه مناطق في خارج اربيل مناطق
مختلفه بالعراق شعروا بالزلزال
وطبعا الاكثر تفاعلا في كل هذه المناطق هم
المناطق السكان الامارات السكنيه في اربيل
ودهوك الذين هرعوا الى الشوارع لحظه
الزلزال وبقوا لاكثر من ساعه خوفا من عوده
او او
اعزائي ارتداديه بالتالي فانه وايضا كان
الامن الكردي قد يطلق الاذاعات لسكان
الامارات
ومجمعات سكنيه في دهوك ان يخلوا وينزلوا
من الامارات
وحتى لا يكون هناك اي اي اضرار او خسائر
لا سمح الله خصوصا وان دهوك هي الاقرب الى
تركيا طبعا من ضمنها مدينه زاخو الحدوديه
مع مناطق اخرى ايضا قريبه من تركيا
وطبعا الحال ينسحب الى اربيل عاصمه اقليم
كردستان في انهم نزلوا الى الشوارع طبعا
صحيح ان شعرت بها مناطق في العراق لكن
لم يكن هناك اي اي خسائر في على الاقل
تقدير حتى الان لم تردنا اي خسار خصوصا
وان سلطات الكرديه في اقليم كردستان اداره
تقليم كردستان تراقب الموضوع عن كثب
وتتابع مع مع كل المناطق سواء كان حدوديه
او داخل المدن تتابع فيما واذكروا هناك
تصدع او او انهيار مباني او لا سمح الله
اي اضرار لم يكن هناك اضرار حتى الان ولم
تسجل حتى الان اي اضرار على اقل تقدير
طبعا الاضرار بالهدم لكن بالتشقق
تصدر اي بيانات وطبعا بانتظار البيانات
الرسميه فيما اذا كان هناك تسجيل لعمارات
ومباني ومنازل قد تصدعت بهذا الزلزال الذي
ايقظ سكان اقليم كردستان على وجه العموم
طبعا
وايضا مناطق
على وجه الخصوص بالقرب
كردستان الموصل وما الى ذلك المناطق
القريبه بالتالي فنحن نراقب
عن كثب فيما اذا كان هناك اي اضرار في
المناطق القريبه من حدود العراقيه التركيه
اخص بالذكر طبعا زاخو زاخو فيها مباني
عاليه وفيها الشقق وايضا عمارات سكنيه
ومجمعات سكنيه استثماريه ربما يكون هناك
اكثر ذعرا من العمق العراقي في اربيل وفي
داخل دهوك واطراف اربيل ودهوك بالجهه
محافظات العراق طيب شكرا لك احمد فقط
نواصل الاشاره الى عدد من الاخبار العاجله
التي نشاهدها الان على شاشه العربيه
العلامه السوريه يتحدث عن وصول عشره قتلى
وعشرات الجرحى الى المستشفيات تحديدا الى
حلب نتيجه هذا الزلزال الذي تاثرت به
المناطق شمال سوريا بالاضافه الى الاراضي
التركيه كما تابعنا اخر الاحصائيات التي
كانت جاءت من تركيا كانت تتحدث عن خمسه
عشر قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى جراء هذا الزلزال
دفاع المدني السوري ايضا يقول بان عشرات
الضحايا والاشخاص لا زالوا عالقين تحت
الانقاض في شمال غرب سوريا وبالتالي هناك
توقعات بارتفاع حصيله هذا الضحى او هذه
الضحايا
اذا نتابع التغطيه نعود مره اخرى الى
تركيا لمتابعه التغطيه ومعنا من اتاي احدى
المناطق المتضرره الصحفي مصطفى النعيمي
مصطفى ما اخر التطورات لديك هل هناك ارقام
جديده بشان الاصابات التي حدثت جرى هذا
الزلزال
يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال بالنعيمي من
هاتاي وذلك بسبب صعوبه الاتصال كما اشرنا
سابقا وزير الداخليه التركي دعا المواطنين
الى التقليل من استخدام شبكه الهواتف
النقاله لتخفيف الضغط والاعطاء الاول
الاولويه لعمليات الانقاذ كما اشرنا سابقا
ايضا لبنان تاثر
بانعكاسات هذا الزلزال معنا من بيروت
غنويتين غنوه هل تم تسجيل اي اصابات او
اضرار جوائز تركيا حتى الان في لبنان
يعني اكتفت يعني فقط الهزه في لبنان اكتفى
على الشعور المواطنون على شعور المواطنين
بها
كان هناك يعني بالطبع ارتجاج للابنيه شعر
هزه قويه كانت شعره بها شعر بها المواطنين
اضطروا بعدها الى اخلاء منازلهم والخروج
من الابنيه بقي هذا الامر لاكثر من ساعه
البعض يعني توجه بسياراته الى مناكب الى
اماكن خاليه خاصه وان هناك معلوم بان
بلبنان هناك الكثير من الابنيه المهدده
المهدده بالانهيار لذلك سكان هذه الابناء
الابنيه اضطروا الى مغادره منازلهم اضافه
الى موضوع الرعب لدى المواطنين التي خلفته
هذه الهزه التي ايضا كان بعدها هزات عشرات
الهزات
الارتداديه ولكن كان هناك تطوينات بان
الامر سيكتفي عند هذا الحد كان هناك
تكبيرات في الشوارع في شمال لبنان وايضا
المس فيها تكبيرات بعد حدوث هذه هذه الهزه
علما ان هذه الهزه الثالثه التي يشعر بها
المواطنين في اقل من شهر يعني هذا رغم ان
هذه كانت الاقوى واستمرت لاربعين ثانيه
تقريبا
ولكن كما ذكرت يعني الاضرار اكتفت على على
هذا الشيء رغم ان هناك كان تداول
لفيديوهات عن سقوط امنيه وما الى هنالك
ولكن تبين لاحقا ان هذه الابنيه هي خارج
لبنان هي في سوريا او في تركيا
طيب شكرا لك غير وحتى الان اذا كما اشرنا
اكثر من مره بان هذا الزلزال قد شعر به
سكان اليونان قبرص العراق وسوريا ولبنان
وارمينيا وهذه المناطق المحابيه التركيه
على البحر المتوسط وهناك تحضيرات من
المراكز البحثيه ومراكز رصد الزلازل بان
موجات تسونامي قد تنجد او تنتج عن هذا
الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته
7.9 على مقياس ريختر اذا نتابع التطورات
من مناطق مختلفه معنا من غازي عنتاب زكريا
ملاحجي عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري ما
الذي حدث في غازي عنتاب هل تم تسجيل اي
اضرار في هذه المنطقه جرار زلزال التركي
سيد زكريا
اهلا وسهلا صباح الخير
هلا حدث في انهيارات لبعض مباني والناس
وفي بحاله ظهر لكن ما معروف لسه وما في
يعني لسا بعد يعني اي ارقام يعني رسميه
لكن في ثلاث مناطق حدث فيها
بانهيار لمباني
بغازي مختار باشا
لكن يعني لسه ما معروف اي اي تفصيل لكن
الوضع الاصعب اللي هو بشمال حلب واللي هو
ايضا طريق قريب جدا في عدد كبيره يعني من
الان عم ينحكى على من عشرين الى 60 كمان
لسا ما في رقم دقيق يعني عن ضحايا بيناتهم
اطفال ونساء والاخره في ناس ما زالت تحت
الركام يعني الوضع وعصير بصراحه لانه
الدرجه عاليه ويعني يعني اتمنى ان احنا
بنحكي عن وحتى المراصد الرسميه بتحكي انه
من عام 1999 لم يحصل بهذا المستوى الى
اليوم يعني نحن بالفين 2023
هذا المستوى بهذا الشكل وبهاي المده هي
منذ 1999 الى اليوم بهذا بهذا الشكل ما
زالت الناس لساته في الشارع ويعني تقريبا
ثلاث ساعات لكن ما زالت الناس
في الشارع ما زالت التحذيرات عم تحكي على
التزام بالساحات العامه والسيارات
والابتعاد عن الابنيه والاخره بعض الناس
بدات ترجع لكن لسه على الوضع يعني
ما زال قلق يعني لكن الوضع الاسوء اللي هو
صراحه بشمال سوريا يعني الابنيه وضعها
وابنيه العشوائيه والى اخره هون الكارثه
اكثر بكثير يعني طبعا في هذه المناطق التي
قد نجت من المعارك ومن القصف سواء كان في
حماه او كان في حلب اشرت الى وجود الكثير
من المباني العشوائيه لان هناك الكثير من
اللاجئين والناجحين الذين عادوا وحاولوا
اعاده البناء بظل غياب تنظيمات جديده فقط
للسكنه وبالتالي هناك توقعات بين ترتفع
اعداد الضحايا جيران انهيار المزيد من
المباني سيد زكريا
اه نعم يعني عم اقول لك يعني الان الحديث
عم يحكوا عن عن يعني 60 ضحيه شبه مؤكده
وما زال الرقم طبعا هذا كل لحظه ببين له
ما زال في هناك تحت الانقراض الدفاع
المدني اطلق ارقام يعني يعني للتواصل بحيث
للابلاغ عن اي انهيار او اي حاله يعني
طارئه
الوضع وضع عصيب بصراحه والقدرات
والامكانات معروفه يعني هي
ضئيله وضعيفه يعني بحاله بحاله بالاصل هي
حاله حرب وغير وغير مستقره ما زال لسه بعض
الناس هون ما بين انطاكيا والريحانيه عم
تحاول تتواصل مع اهاليا لعله تحصل على
يعني خبر لانه في انهيارات
واطلقوا انذار بانه يعني فنحن بنحكي عن عن
كارثه موجوده في جنوب تركيا في شمال سوريا
لكن كيف حتكون الامور طبعا كان في تصدعات
في الشوارع بطريق الريحانيه وعم ينحكى على
انه يعني اختلالات بالقشره الارضيه بعمق
عشره كيلو متر
فالوضع يعني حقيقه ما شاهد مثله منذ
التسعينات الى اليوم يعني بهذا الحجم
وبهاي الخطوره ونسال الله السلام من
الجميع يعني ان شاء الله طيب ذكرت بان
السكان لا زالوا خارج منازلهم خوفا من
انهيار المباني جراء الهزات الارتداديه
وحتى الوسائل التحذيريه اللي عم تيجي من
الولايه والافاد ومراكز الطوارئ وكذا انه
الناس تكون بعيده تكون بالساحات لا زالت
الناس بالساحات بعض الناس بدات ترجع لانه
يعني حاله الطقس تحت الصفر نحن عم نحكي عن
ثلوج المنطقه كلها مغطاه شمال سوريا جنوب
تركيا كلها مغطى بالثلوج بالفتره الاخيره
بعض الناس ما بتحاول ترجع بعض الناس لا
زالت في الغالبيه لساتهم في الفساحات
العامه
طيب اذا نتابع هذه التغطيه شكرا لزكريا
ملاح
الوطني سوري ونشير الى ان هذه الهزات
الارتداديه وتاثيراتها ايضا وصلت الى
مناطق مختلفه خارج الحدود تركيا نعم مركز
الزلزال داخل الاراضي التركيه ولكن
تداعيات هذه
الهزه وصلت الى العراق وصلت الى لبنان الى
الى الى الى سوريا كما اشرنا قبل قليل
خاصه مدينتي حلب وحماه بعد انهيار عدد من
المنازل
اصابه عدد من الاشخاص بالاضافه الى عدد من
القتلى الذين وصلوا الى المستشفيات
بانتظار ارقام جديده هذه الهزه ايضا وصلت
الى مناطق مثل ارمينيا اليونان قبرص
ومحاديه ايضا حتى الى مصر ونتابع معكم هذه
الصور وهذه اللقطات لاثار الدمار في بعض
المناطق التي وقع فيها هذا الزلزال في
تركيا
وهذه تغطيه مستمره ينضم الينا من القاهره
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي
عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيد رامي بما انك
موجود في القاهره هل شعرت الهزه الارضيه
وماذا عن الانباء التي وردت من سوريا خاصه
في حلب وحماه جراء هذه الهزه الارضيه التي
ضربت تركيا نعم حقيقه الامر كنت يعني مع
مرافيني المرصد بعد
نتيجه وقوع الهزه الارضيه والمخاوف التي
ارتابت الكثير في الشمال السوري صباح
الخير اولا حتى اللحظه نتحدث نحن عن 45
ضحيه في في مناطق سوريا مختلفه من مناطق
سيطره النظام الى مناطق سيطره المعارضه
السيطره التركيه سيطره قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه اي ان في مناطق عده كان هناك
ضحايا 45 ضحيه على الاقل وفيات وعشرات
الاصابات بالاضافه لعشرات المنازل
المتهدمه التي انهارت على رؤوس ساكنيها
وهناك بعض المنازل التي انهارت ولم يكن
فيها فاكرين وهذا شيء يعني جيد ولكن يعني
المناطق التي انهارت فيها المباني تتركز
في غرض سوريا في وسط سوريا في شمال غرب
سوريا وفي شمال سوريا اي ان هذه البقعه من
التراب السوري كان فيها الضحايا او جميع
الضحايا او العدد الاكبر من الضحايا حتى
الان لان هناك معلومات عن وجود ضحايا في
مناطق سوريا متاخمه للحدود التركيه
يعني الخسائر البشريه حقيقه امل تركزت على
المناطق المجاوره اللواء اسكندرون وايضا
المناطق المقايسه محاذيه للجنوب التركي
وبالاضافه لمدينه حلب وجبله اي ان مناطق
سوريا مختلفه هي التي كان فيها الخسائر
البشريه الاكبر من شعرها في الزلزال يعني
على سبيل المثال وقت وقوع زلزال في دمشق
مراسل المرصد في اقصى شمال شرق سوريا في
شمال غرب سوريا جميعهم تحدثوا عن الزلزال
في الميادين في مناطق سوريا مختلفه ولكن
الكارثه الاكبر كانت على منطقه الاقوى
لسنسال وهي شمال غرب سوريا التي وقعت فيها
الخسائر البشريه الاكبر فقط نذكر السيد
رامي بحصيله هذه الضحايا في الاراضيه
السوريه كنا نتحدث عن انهيار عدد من
المباني ومحاصره عدد من الاشخاص تحت
الركام حتى الان في ظل ربما عجز سلطات
المختصه سواء في المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
النظام المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الفصائل الاخرى
وصعوبه انقاذهم حتى الان هل هناك اي ارقام
يمكن الحديث عنها تحديدا
النهل تحلق ما لا يقول عن 45 من الوفيات
هناك عشرات لم نقل مئات اصابات حتى الان
لا يستطيع اعطاء رقم دقيق عن الاصابات
المباني التي نتحدث عنها ليس مبنى او
مبدئيا هناك مباني كثيره انهارت المؤكده
هناك مباني لا احد يعلم بانه يوجد فيها
سكان نتيجه ترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه البعض
يعيش في مباني اي للسقوط مباني تضررت
نتيجه القصف الجوي والحرب في سوريا لذلك
اقول بان العدد قد يرتفع في اي لحظه عندما
تكتشف الفرق الطبيه او فرق الانقاذ بان
هناك مدنيين كانوا قاتلين في هذه المباني
على رؤوسهم سواء في مدينه حلب سواء في
منطقه ادلب سواء في شمال غرب حلب سواء حتى
في المنطقه التي انهار فيها مبنى قبل
اسابيع في حي الشيخ مبسوط ايضا كان هناك
وفيات لذلك اقول بان العدد هو مرشح
للارتفاع في اي لحظه انت تعيش في منطقه
يعني يوجد فيها قصف جوي وكان وانفجارات
عاما ونحن نتحدث الان عن زلزال قوي اصاب
تلك المنطقه طيب هذه مشكله اخرى وكارثه
لان عدد الضحايا المسجل حتى الان في
الاراضي التركيه لم يبلغ هذا الرقم نتحدث
هنا عن 45 قتيل في المناطق السوريه التي
تضررت جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
في منزل هو يعني قد يتهدى في اي لحظه
نتيجه اي عامل ما بالك زلزال قوي ضرب
الاراضي السوريه نتحدث عن مناطق مباني
انشات خلال السنوات القادمه العصر الماضيه
يعني بطرق غير يعني شرعيه او باسس اساس
غير يعني قابل للانشاء وانشات طوابق عده
في تلك المناطق نتحدث في مدينه حلب على
سبيل المثال الكثير او في محافظه حلب
الكثير من المباني الايه للسقوط يوجد فيها
سكان لانهم لا يملكون ان يدفعوا اجار شقه
في مبنى يعني
مؤهل للعيش للحياه الكريمه هناك الكثير لو
اصابت لهزه لو كانت قوه الهزه في كامل
التراب السوري لشاهدنا عدد ضحايا اكبر من
ذلك بكثير لان هناك الكثير من العائلات
تعيش في هذه المباني التي قد تنهدم على
رؤيتها بدون زلزال
طب اذا نتابع هذه اللقطات وهذه الصور وكما
ذكر رامي عبد الرحمن قبل قليل بان الرقم
45 قتيلا على الاقل
جراء هذا الزلزال في مناطق شمال غربي
سوريا وهذا الرقم مرجح للارتفاع طيب نختم
فقط رامي بالحديث عن جهود الانقاذ هل
تمتلك السلطات السوريه او المعارضه او
الفصائل السوريه اي امكانيات لمواجهه
كارثه بهذا الحجم
اعتقد انها تمتلك لانها لو كانت تمتلك لما
ارتفع عدد الضحايا من بدايه بضعه وفيات
الى 45 وصيه وقد يرتفع الى اكبر من ذلك
بكثير نحن نتحدث عن اعداد وانهيارات في
مناطق مختلفه ولا الفرق الطبيه غير قادره
عن يعني تفي بالامكانيات لمساعده المصابين
جميعهم قد يساعدونهم اذا ما جاءت فرق طبيه
بالمناطق السوريه مختلفه ولكن الفرق
الطبيه يعني على ارض الواقع لا تتمكن ولم
تتمكن من انقاذ جميع الضحايا ضحايا
الزلزال الذين مثل ما ذكرنا ووصل عددهم
الى ما لا يكون عن 45 ضحيه الى الان في
مناطق سوريا مختلفه فقط في نقطه اضافيه
فقط بما اننا نتحدث عن
صعوبه انقاذ او الوصول الى المحاصرين تحت
المباني من اين يمكن ان تاتي المساعدات
الى الاراضي السوريه في هذه المرحله
الدقيقه ونحن نتحدث عن مناطق متضرره بعد
سنوات من الحرب في سوريا
يوجد هناك كثير من قوات الاحتلال داخل
الاراضي السوريه هذه يجب ان تساعد ضحايا
لا تساعد بقتل السوريين يعني هناك قوه عده
لديها امكانيات على الاراضي السوريه من
التركيه الى الايرانيه الامريكيه الى
الروسيه يجب ان يساعدوا ابناء الشعب
السوري الان يساعده الفرق الطبيه لا
يقومون بجلوس في مقراتهم بهدوء ومن ثم
يعني ينظرون الى هؤلاء الضحايا الذين لا
تتمكن الفرق السوريه من انقاذهم واخراجهم
من تحت المباني المهدمه رامي عبد الرحمن
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان شكرا
جزيلا لك وهذه التغطيه دائما مستمره لما
تتابعونه من هذا الدمار الهائل الذي ضرب
عده مناطق في تركيا وفي الشمال الغربيه
السوري
وتضررت منه ايضا مباني في العراق
وفي بعض المناطق الاخرى المجاوره
للحدود التركيه اذا هذه صور الدمار التي
ترد سواء من وكالات الانباء او المحطات
الرسميه او حتى من خلال وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
والجهود دائما مستمره للعثور على ناجين
تحت
ركام المباني والابراج التي وقعت والتي
بلغت بالعشرات في اكثر من منطقه تركيا
وكذلك في الاراضي السوريه كما تبعنا قبل
قليل اذا الجهود مستمره ويبدو بان اعداد
الاصابات وحصيله الضحايا سترتفع بشكل كبير
في ظل تاخر الوصول الى المزيد من الناجين
جراء هذا الزلزاله نترككم مع هذه الصور
تغطيه من اسطنبول مع الزميل لزيدان زنكلو
اهلا بك زيدان ما اخر الارقام المتوفره
لديك وجهود الانقاذ حتى اللحظه
نعم محمد حتى الان الحصيله الاوليه تشير
الى ان عدد الضحايا تجاوزوا الخمسين شخصا
في ثلاثه ولايات فقط نتحدث عن ولايات ديار
بكر التي شهدت نصها سته اشخاص واصابه 79
اخرين نتحدث عني لايه شانلي اورفا التي
شهدت
تقريبا تحدث والي اورفان ان 15 شخصا لقوا
مصاعهم ايضا والي ملاطيا حتى الان الحصيه
الاكبر في مناطق التي تريدون حتى الان
تحدث عن
حوالي او نص 23 شخصا واصابه 420
دمار ايضا
دمار 140 مبنى ايضا في الولايات العثمانيه
كان والي العثمانيه صرح في وقت سابق من
فجر هذا اليوم ان خمسه اشخاص لقوا مصائهم
وان حوالي 34 بناء
في السلام مره نتيجه هذا الزلزال اذا
نتحدث عن حصيله اوليه تجاوزت الخمسين شخصا
فقط في اربع ولايات وليس في ثلاث ولايات
حتى الان الولايات الاهرامات مرعش التي
ضربها الزلزال لا نعلم حتى الان عن اعداد
الضحايا هناك لم يتم الاعلام او اصدار
بيانات رسميه ايضا ولايه غازي عنتاب التي
شهدت زلزالا اخر بلغت شبته 6.6 بعد 15
دقيقه فقط من الزلزال الاول الذي ضربك
امام مرعش حتى الان ايضا لم يتصل معلومات
من ولايه غازي عنتاب البيانات الرسميه من
هناك لكن نتحدث عن ان دمار كبير نتحدث عن
عشر ولايات تضررت او تاثرت في الزلزال
والهزاف الارتداديه نتحدث عن دمار في لا
يقل عن اربع او خمس ولايات بحسب ما رسمناه
من هذه الولايه بالعشره ساتابع معك
التفاصيل واخر التطورات تباعا ولكن دعونا
نتح
عهد الصليبي على عهد نتابع معك اذا عمليات
الانقراض في الموقع الذي تتواجد فيه
المشاهدين نحن الان امام المبنى الذي سقط
في
وسط مدينه اورفا سقطت البنات عدد من
القتلى والجرحى في هذا المكان كذلك الامر
كذلك الامر سقطت العديد من الابنيه في
ولايه شارلي اوروبا بحسب بعض عناصر
الاطفاء
الطبيه بانه سته عشر بناء تم دمرت جرار
هذه الهزه الارضيه في ولايه شان لاورفا
اعداد ضحايا كبيره جدا حقيقه في هذا
البناء عندما وصلنا بعد 20 دقيقه من يعني
سقوطه كان هناك بعض الصيحات من داخل هذا
البناء من
اهالي هذا البناء بناء مؤلف كما ترون من
خمس طوابق سقطت جميعها على الارض كذلك
الامر في حي يعني شهير سقط بناء ايضا مكون
من ست طوابق سقط فيه ثمانيه قتلى وعدس
كبير من الجرح كذلك الامر في حي احمد
ارصوان ايضا بداخل
سقطت عدد من الابنيه واحد منها سقط فيه
ايضا عدد من القتلى والجراحه حتى الان لا
توجد اي احصائيه رسميه كما ترون خلف تماما
عمليات الانقاذ تجري في هذا البناء يعني
لا يوجد اي حصيل نهائيه لهذه العمليه ما
هو ماساوي اكثر هو درجات الحراره المنخفضه
في هذه المنطقه التي يعني بسبب هذه الهزه
خرج الاهالي الى الساحات والى الحدائق
والشوارع خوفا من الضربات الابتداديه ومن
الهزه الارضيه الهزه الارضيه التي ضربت
المنطقه الان الاهالي جميعهم كما ترون
خلفي تماما منتشرون في الحدائق والشوارع
هنا عمليات اللجنه تتم في حي برشلونه جرار
سقوط هذا البناء المكون خمس طوابق ايضا
مشفى ال 500 في ولايه شادو اورفا طلبت
يعني جميع زمر الدم للتبرع فيها حتى الان
هناك تخوف من الضربات الابتداديه من الهزه
الارضيه وجميع الاهالي في الشوارع الاطفال
والنساء جميعهم يقفون هنا
لتفادي للاضرار التي تحصد جميع المنازل في
ولايه اورفا تضررت جراء هذه الهزه بعض
الابنيه القديمه هي من سقطت وخلفت هذه
الاعداد الكبيره من القتلى والجرحى هذا
تقريبا كل ما يحصل حتى الان في ولايه شادو
اوروبا طيب عهد
كلنا صور بشكل مباشر نستطيع الاستماع اليك
من خلال الصوت تابع لنا عمليات الانقاذ
ومحاولات انتشار المزيد من الضحايا جراء
انهيار هذا المبنى متعدد الطوابق في شهر
نتابع معك عهد
وعمليات الاجلاء ما زالت مستمره اذا سمحت
هنا كما ترون
اذا نتابع معهد ما زالت محاولات الانقاذ
مستمره هناك مركبات واليه
للسلطات المحليه في محاوله لرفع الركام
وعدد من
اثار الانهيار في هذا المبنى الذي نشاهده
في هذه الصوره هناك توقعات
بارتفاع عدد القتلى والاصابات كما نتابع
مع عهد الكلمه لك عهد تابعه لنا ايضا
المزيد من التفاصيل حول الاستمرار عمليات
الانقاذ والجهود التي تمارسها سلطات من
اجل انقاذ الضحايا
هذا البناء كما ترون هو مؤلف من خمسه
طوابق سقطت كلها دفعه واحده ايضا الابنيه
المجاوره تضررت بشكل كبير هذه المنطقه
تسكنها الغالبيه من السوريين حيدر الوسطى
في ولايه شان اورفا يعني تعد ولايه شارلي
اورفا كانت الملاذ الاول لاهالي المناطق
الشرقيه من سوريا لجاوا الى هذه المناطق
تقدر احصائيه السوريين الموجودين في هذه
المنطقه وتحديدا من المحافظات الشرقيه
بحوالي 500 الف مواطن سوري في هذه المنطقه
هناك ضحايا سوريين جراء هذه الهزه والهزات
الارتداديه التي نتجت عنها لكن حتى الان
لم نستطيع توثيق اي اسم من الضحايا سواء
كانوا من القتلى والجرحى هناك ايضا في
ولايه مرعش في الجنوب التركي عائله من
اقاربي ما زالوا تحت الانقاض يعني عائله
محمد التبان عائله مؤلفه لا يقارب خمس
اشخاص ما زالوا جميعهم تحت الالقاب قبل
دقيقه من الان تم اخراج الرجل
افراد العائله تحت الانصار حتى الان لم
تتبين ما هي صحتهم ان تم اجلائهم او هم
يعني قضوا حقيقه لا توجد اي تفاصيل حول
هذه العمليه نقطه اخرى ايضا ذكرت عهد بان
عدد من اقاربك في كهرمان مرعش ما زالوا
محاصرين تحت الانقاذ وهم كغيرهم من
المدنيين الذين تضرروا وحوصروا في المباني
التي انهارت جراء هذا الزلزال سواء كان في
تركيا او في شمال الغربي السوري
[موسيقى]
معك هذه الصور عهد
هل تسمعني نعم نسمعك ونتابع معك هذه
اللقطات المباشره على شاشه العربيه
السلطات التركيه اذا تحاول انقذ ما يمكن
انقاضه
وانتشار الضحايا المدنيين المحاصرين تحت
الركاب في هذه المباني التي انهارت جرى
زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا فجر اليوم اذا نشاهد
هذه اللقطات من جوال عهد صليبي من شبكه
نهر ميديا الذي تواجد في عين المكان في
شاليه اورفا في تركيا لمتابعه محاوله
انتشار المزيد من او انقاذ المزيد من
الضحايا الجراء انهيار هذا المبنى المكون
من خمسه طوابق في شاليه اورفا في هذه
المنطقه المزدحمه بالمباني في تركيا
عذرا اذا كانت الصوره متديه لكن بسبب يعني
تساقط الامطار على المنطقه ويعترض او
تشويش في العدسه وكذلك الامر بسبب التدافع
للاهالي المتواجدين في المنطقه والشرطه
التي تحاول يعاد الناس عن هذا المكان حتى
لا يتضرروا
كما نتابع معهد سلطات التركيه شرطه
التركيه تحاول ابعاد
المكان وايضا الصحفيين كما الحال مع عهد
لمتابعه محاولات الانقاذ المستمره كمرتابع
في هذه اللقطات المباشره بالتاكيد حادث من
هذا النوع لا يتطلب ربما تقنيات عاليه
وصور عاليه ربما كاميرا جوال قد تنقل
للساده المشاهدين الصوره بحذافيرها دون
رتوش او دون مونتاج او دون تعديل لكن
العهد بالنسبه لهذا المبنى تحديدا هل تم
تسجيل عدد ضحايا معين جراء انهياري حتى
الان وهل نتوقع
اشخاص محاصرين داخل هذا المبنى وهل الرقم
معروف حتى الان
بمبنى اعتقد غبت عن هذا المكان لوقت قصير
ثم عدد اعتقد انهم اخرجوا هذا الشخص الذي
كان ينادي
لانقاده من من الركام التي كانت يعني
متجمعه فوق
جسده كذلك الامر بدايه وصولنا الى المكان
تحدث عناصر الاطفاء والصحيه بان هناك
ضحايا تم انتشالهم لكن لم يتم التاكيد اذا
كانوا قد توفوا بشكل مباشر هم كانوا يعني
مصابين فقط لكن باعتقادي ان هناك عدد من
الضحايا وقتلوا بشكل مباشر في في دراسه
هذا البلاء الان
المكان
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد عهد هناك محاولات اذا
لاخلاء المكان من الصحفيين والمتجمهرين من
اجل مواصله عمليه الانقاذ وبالتاكيد وجود
هذا الكمل هذا الملليات يعني بتسجيل وجود
اشخاص محاصرين تحت الركاب نتحدث بشكل عام
عهد ما المعلومات الوارده لكم من هذه
الولايه
والولايات التركيه الاخرى وحتى من الاراضي
السوريه عن وجود ضحايا او اصابات دراز
زلزال تركيا
نعم وكما ذكرت لك قبل قليل وبجوله سريعه
على بعض المجموعات التي تجمعنا مع صحفيين
السوريين المتواجدين في الجنوب التركي
تحدثوا عن اعداء يعني عن ضحايا اعداد
كبيره
في هذه
الارضيه تحدثت لك في ولايه شارلي اورفا
اعداد الابنيه بحسب يعني مصادر شبه رسميه
بانها سته عشر بناء اعداد القتلى كما ذكرت
لك في هذا البناء سقطت قتله لكن لا يوجد
حتى الان اي حصيله رسميه بالتواصل مع بعض
المصادر من المشافي الحكوميه قالوا ان
الاعداد كبيره جدا وكان هناك يعني عبر
المذياع يطالبون
يطالبون
بالتبرع بكافه زمر الدم يعني حقيقه ذكرت
لك اكثر الابنيه التي تضررت هي في
حيلولر وحي احمد ارثوان وكذلك الامر في حي
يعني قبل قليل ايضا كنت في حي بام يسوء
الذي ايضا تقتله الغالبيه السوريه سقطت
اجزاء من من مئذنه الجامع الجديد في هذا
الحي لكن على ما يبدو انه لم يتضرر اي احد
وكذلك الامر بعض اسلاك الكهرباء
سقطت ايضا في الشارع حقيقه هذا كلما يجري
الان ربما خلال الساعات القليله القادمه
تتبين لنا الصوره الصوره بشكل واضح عن
اعداد الضحايا والقتل وربما ايضا نكون
معكم عبر الهواء مباشره من المشافي
الحكوميه
شكرا لكن هربكم مع سنعود اليك بعد قليل
لمتابعه اخر التطورات من العين المكان في
هذا المكان الذي شاهد انهيار عدد من
المباني
ووجود عدد من الاشخاص المحاصرين اذا عمليه
الانقاذ مستمره وفي اكثر من منطقه سواء في
الاراضي التركيه والاراضي السوريه وهي
المناطق الاكثر تضررا ربما جرى هذا
الزلزال الذي شعر به سكان مناطق مجاوره
للاراضي السوريه
التركيه نتابع الارقام ونحدث المعلومات
حتى الان مع الزميل زيدان
ما الجديد
طيب اذا نتابع نعم كنت اسالك عن اخر
الارقام والاحصائيات جرائز التركي حتى لا
نعم
احصائيه كما ذكرت تجاوزت الخمسين شخصا
ابدا في الحصيله الاكبر في ملاطيه حيث
الحصيله ما زالت كما اعلنها وادي مناطق
قبل قليل ثلاثه وعشرين شخص
لقوم صاعون في شان اورفا خمسه عشر شخصا
لقوم اصبعهم و30 شخصا مصابا في شهر اوروبا
بينما عدد المصابين في ملاقيه كان حوالي
420 في العثمانيه 65 مبنى دمر وايضا خمسه
اشخاص لقوا مصائهم ايضا في تشارلي اورفا
كنا او في اضنه ايضا هناك حديث عن انهيار
عدد من المباني الحديث عن ثلاثه مباني
وتصدى في 17
مبنى اخر ايضا كنا نتحدث عن شامي اورفا
التي بلغ عدد الضحايا فيها خمسه عشر شخصا
في العثمانيه كان والي عثمان يتحدث عن
خمسه اشخاص
كل الجهود الان المستنفره حتى الوصول الى
المناطق المتضرره عشر ولايات تقريبا تضررت
نتيجه الزلزال كل هذه الولايات هي
الولايات الجنوبيه اجهزه الدوله بالكامل
في حاله استنفار حتى القوات المسلحه
التركيه وضعت طائراتها على اهدده
الاستعداد لنقل الطواقم الطبيه وفرق
الانقاذ الى مباشره الى المناطق الجنوبيه
الهلال الاحمر التركي
يعلن ايضا عن
نقاط للتبرع في الدم في حال استدعت او
طلبت المشافي في الولايات الجنوبيه اي
مساعدات عاجله بالعموم نتحدث عن دمار في
عدد لا يقل عن اربع او خمسه ولايات شهدت
تضررا كبيرا حتى الان المنطقه التي ضربها
الزلزال والتي المتوقع ان يكون فيها حجم
الدمار الاكبر هي ولايه كهرمان مرعش وايضا
ولايه غازي عنتاب التي ضربها زلزال اخر
بقوه 6.6
بعد الزلزال الاول 15 دقيقه هاتان
الولايتين لم تصدر عنهما ايه تصريحات
رسميه عن اعداد الضحايا اعداد الهزات
الارتداديه تقريبا التي ثلاث الزلزال
تتجاوز 30 هزه نتحدث عن 32 او 32 هزه
ارتداديه شهدتها هذه الولايات العشره بعد
الزلزال الرئيسي الذي ضرب
كهرمان من مرعش وبقوه 7.4 طبعا وزير
الداخليه التركي قبل قليل سليمان صالح
اعلن عن اطلاق الانذار من المستوى الرابع
وهذا يعني طلب مساعده دوليه عاجله من
لتركيا بالتالي هذا ينبئ بشكل او باخر
محمد عن ان نحن امام كارثه وعدد ربما عدد
ضحايا تكون كبيره جدا وايضا الدمار يكون
كبير جدا هذا الان تصحيح دوالي كهرمان
مرعش يتحدث انه لا يستطيع حتى الان ان
يعطي احصائيه رسميه عن اعداد الضحايا وكما
ذكرت يعني الاعلان السلطات التركيه درجه
الانذار او من المرتبه
الرابعه هذا ينبغي ان ان حجم الكارثه كبير
نتحدث عن عشر ولايات تضررت
بزلزال شدته 7.4 هذا اكبر زلزال ربما حتى
الان بحسب ما اعلم منذ زلزال الشهير الذي
ضرب اسطنبول في عام 1999 والذي راح ضحيته
اكثر من 17000 قتيل وضحيه خلال
ذاك الزلزال نتحدث تقريبا عن حاله مشابهه
لكن هذه المره
تضرب عشره ولايات تركيه ولذلك ربما نتحدث
عن اعداد اصابات كبيره وايضا على ضحايا
كبيره الموضوع لم يتوقف هنا ايضا
نتحدث عن اعداد ضحايا العشرات في شمال
سوريا تحديدا في المناطق ما بين اداء
الدانه في ريف ادلب الشمالي وايضا عفرين
ريف حلب الشمالي هذه المناطق التي تقع تحت
السيطره المعارضه هناك العشرات ممن ما
زالوا تحت الانقاض تحت الانقاض وفرق
الدفاع المدني معتزاز تحاول الوصول اليهم
ايضا
الزلزال في العاصمه السوريه دمشق سمع او
حتى السكان هناك في الزلزال وهناك ضحايا
في حلب وايضا في الساحل السوري كل هذه
الانباء ما زالت اوليه هنا اعداد ضحايا
مرشحه للارتفاع الاساسيه في شمال سوريا
وفي جنوب تركيا نحن نتحدث هنا زيدان عن
100 قتيل على الاقل نتحدث هنا عن الاقل
باستثناء طبعا عش المصابين والاشخاص الذين
لا زالوا محاصرين تحت ركام حتى الان اذا
كانت السلطات التركيه قد اعلنت بانها قد
رفعت مستوى التوحد الى المركز الرابع
وبالتالي السماح باستقبال المساعدات
الدوليه للمساهمه في تفادي
عواقب هذه الكارثه والمساعده في انتشال
الضحايا كيف هو الحال مثلا في الاراضي
السوريه المدمره اصلا سنوات من الحرب وهل
مثلا
السلطات التركيه ستساهم او اعلنت انها
ستساهم مثلا بمسانده المناطق المتضرره
ايضا على الجانب السوري كونها هي الدوله
المحاذيه لتلك المناطق الحدوديه زيدان هل
هناك اي اعلان من هذا النوع
حتى الان لا يوجد اي اعلان من الحكومه
التركيه
لاي ارسال اي طواقم طبيه للداخل السوري لم
لم نسمع او لم يشاهد اي اعلان من هذا
القبيل لكن بطبيعه الحال اعتقد ان
الامكانيات الموجوده هناك حتى سواء
الطواقم المدعومه من انقره او المنظمات
المدعومه من انقره لا يمكن ان تلبي الحاجه
في مثل هذه الكوارث في شمال سوريا على
اعتبار ان هذه المناطق هي مناطق نزوح فيها
الملايين من الاشخاص الذين نجحوا الى هذه
المناطق القريبه من الحدود خلال 11 عاما
الماضيه لذلك حسب معرفتي واطلاع على الوضع
هناك اعتقد ان الامكانيات الموجوده هناك
غير كافيه للتعاطي مع مثل هذه الكارثه هذه
الكوارث بحاجه
قبل قليل صور اوليه من كاميرا مراقبه رصدت
اللحظات الاولى لوقوع هذا الزلزال فنتابع
معك وساده المشاهدين هذه اللقطات
[تصفيق]
طيب اذا نتابع الان التطورات ايضا من
الشمال سوريا هي المناطق المتضرره مع مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري الخوض البيضاء رائد
صالح
رائد هل هناك اي لديك حول الاضرار الناتجه
عن زلزال تركي على الاراضي السوريه حتى
الان
ما سمعت عن الزلزال كيف تجري عمليه
الانقاذ حتى الان لانقاذ ضحايا زلزال
تركيا
الان متواجده في المناطق التي
تعرضت حقيقه لكارجيه حقيقيه سوريا لم
تتعرض قبل ذلك لهكذا زلزال ولكن
استنفرنا كافه فرقنا لدينا نحن اكثر من
200 فريق
موجودين
بالمنطقه والان هم يعملون في المناطق
الاكثر تضررا يعني بعد عمليه التقييم
الاولي لكافه شمال غرب سوريا بكافه
المناطق المحرره بدانا نوجه الفرق من
المناطق التي لم تحدث بها اضرار المناطق
الاكثر ايضا كمدينه سرمدا وحارم وسلقين
وايضا ريف سلقين
الدانه والاثارب والديني وجنديرس
والحجم الاضرار كبيره جدا هناك مباني
كثيره جدا على الارض حقيقه يعني رغم كل
الخبرات التي تمتلكها فرق الفوز البيضاء
الذي حق حقيقه يعني انا يعني ارد على
الضيف السابق الذي يتكلم انه لا يوجد
خبره هناك
لا نتحدث هنا عن تشكيك في امكانياتكم ولا
جهودكم ولكن هناك حجم كارثه كبيره جدا
وقعت في المنطقه حدثنا عن جهود الانقاذ لو
تكرمت
حقيقه يعني اقول بانه سبب الكبيره جدا هي
بسبب عمليات القصف السابقه وان المباني هي
غير مستقره المباني هي غير
قادره على التحمل هكذا نوع من الزلازل هذا
الحجم بهذا الضعف هناك حقيقه مستمره
لعمليات الانقاذ قبل دقائق من الان تم
استخراج امراه وطفله من تحت الانقاض
بمدينه سرمدا ايضا تم اخراج ثلاثه اطفال
في مدينه حارم تم الان عمليات البحث
والانقاذ مستمره في منطقه الرمادي هناك
انهيار لبنايات كامله ايضا عمليه المحسوم
قال مستمره في جسر الشغور والملان تم
استخراج ايضا عدد من الجرحى وتم نقلهم الى
المستشفيات
عشرات الققيقه ومئات الجرحى لدينا يعني
تركيا كدوله اصدرت انذار للاتجاه بدوليه
لعمليه الانذار
لتطلب المساعده الدولي ايضا نحن مناطقنا
بحاجه الى مساعده وبحاجه الى زياده دعم
لهذه المنطقه حقيقه ما تعانيه فرقنا هو
نقص في
الامدادات بالوقود فعليا نعاني من نقص
التمويل هذه المناطق ونحن الان من الوقود
الاحتياطي نستمر
طبعا بالتاكيد هناك مشكله في في الصوت
ولكن نريد الحصول على المزيد من المعلومات
فرقكم الميدانيه رائد التي تتواجد الان في
المناطق الاكثر
هل هناك ارقام فيما يتعلق بالمحاصرين
بالضحايا بالقتله ما نوعيه المساعدات التي
تريدونها من اجل انقاذ المزيد من الضحايا
حتى الان
اذا اردنا ان نطلب مساعدات هناك نوعين من
المساعدات المساعدات الاولى هي تقديم
المساعده العاجله لطرقه الدفاع المدني
وللمستشفيات امداداتها بالمواد الطبيه
وامداد فرق الدفاع المدني بالديزل
والمعدات التي ساعدها في الاسراء من عمليه
البحث والانقاذ هناك تضامن من المدنيين
ومساعدين المدنيين نحن
نستثمر كل الجهود المساعده الاخرى هي
تقديم مساعده للمدنيين الذين
في المناطق الخاليه وهم مئات الالاف حقيقه
لانه المباني هناك مباني ايضا كثيره
متصدعه غير قادره الناس اذ تعود اليها وهي
بحاجه الى
اغاثه بحاجه الى مواد تدفئه بشكل سريع اضف
الى ذلك عدد الاحصاء دعني ان اعود الى
الارقام حقيقه لا يوجد ارقام الى دقيقه
مئه بالمئه
موجودين ولكن هناك في احد المستشفيات يوجد
11 قتيل في مستشفيات اخرى يوجد تس هناك
مستشفى اخر يوجد حوالي 13 قتيل واعتقد بكل
مستشفى وصل اليها عدد من القتلى ومئات
نحن نعمل بكل طاقه لنا
فرقنا تركز فعليا جهودها على عمليات البحث
والانقاذ على عمليات اسعاف الجرحى وتقديم
الاسعافات الاوليه وتقديم
المساعده للمتضررين الاحصائيات اعتقد مع
مرور الوقت نستطيع ان نتاكد اكثر من
الاحصائيات ولا نقصد اعتقد نحن الان هي
لانقاذ المزيد من المحاصرين تحت الركام
ولكن ما اكثر المناطق تضررا في سوريا رعد
مناشده الى اخوتنا في الدول العربيه ان
يقدموا المساعده باسرع وقت ممكن اسمح لي
ايضا ان نوجه مناسبه الى اهلنا في سوريا
بان يبتعدوا عن المباني في الفتره الحاليه
وان ينتظروا حتى يظهر الضوء بشكل واضح حتى
نستطيع الجميع تقييم الاضرار وتقييم
المباني التي تعرضت لتضرر كبير بسبب
الزلزال حتى لا يعود الى منازلهم ويكون
هناك تارجه اخرى بانهيار هذه المباني لانه
هذه المباني هي ايضا غير سببتي كثير من
المباني تعرضت لاطلاق سابقه بسبب عمليات
القصف الممنهج الروسي
والنظام السوري لذلك نحن ندعوا للابتعاد
حاليا عن المباني حتى نستطيع ان يضمنوا
سلامتهم وبعدها تتم العمل من قبل المنظمات
على تقديم لغاتهم طيب فقط رائد نشير الى
ان مصادر العربيه تتحدث عن ان حصيله القتل
جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وتاثرت
فيه مناطق سوريا بالتحديد الشمال الغربي
السوري بلغت 100 قتيل وبالتاكيد عشرات
المصابين والمحاصرين انت رائد تحدثت عن
ربما الله اكبر
فيما يتعلق بالخدمات الطبيه والاليات
لانقاذ الضحايا المحاصرين تحت ركاب حتى
الان من اين يمكن ايصال تلك المساعدات
ونحن نتحدث بان تركيا في المقابل مشغوله
ايضا بوجود انهيارات في مباني عده وجود
العشرات من الاشخاص محاصرين تحت المباني
ما المناطق التي يمكن ادخال المساعدات
التي تحدثت عنها الى سوريا
حقيقه الطريقه الاسهل لايصال المساعدات هي
عن طريق
الصوت يتقطع قليلا هل ممكن تعيد فقط
المعلومه الاخيره التي ذكرتها اذا كنت
لازلت تسمعني من اين يمكن ايصال المساعدات
الى سوريا
يبدو باننا فقط الاتصال مع رائد صالح من
الخوض البيضاء في شمال سوريا وكان يتحدث
عن
توقعات بارتفاع اعداد الضحايا زياده على
الرقب الذي اشرنا اليه من مراسل العربيه
اكثر من 100 قتيل جرازال في سوريا وحدها
وربما رقم مماثل لم يعلن عنه رسميا حتى
الان في الاراضي
السوريه نتابع تفاصيل مره اخرى من زيدان
زينكن وزيدان كنا نتحدث قبل قليل عن
احصائيات قد تصل الى اكثر من خمسين قتيلا
جراز زلزال الذي ضرب الاراضي التركيه هل
هناك من المعلومات اضافيه حتى الان
نعم محمد حتى الان قبل دقائق اعلنت هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه اخر حصيله رسميه
وبلغت 76
شخصا لقوا مصنوعهم وحوالي 440 شخصا مصابا
هذه الحصيره الرسميه لكن اعتقد ان الارقام
اكبر بكثير لان فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تحاول
الوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقراض لكن
تتعاطى الان مع الحصيله الرسميه التي
تحدثت عن سته او التي تتحدث عن 76 شخصا
كما ذكرت اعتقد ان الحصيله اكبر من ذلك
لان فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تواصل الوصول الى
او تحاول الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره
نتحدث عن عشره ولايات تضررت او هناك ادراك
في عشره ولايات تقريبا
غازي عنتاب كل العثمانيه اضنه وايضا
باضافه الى طبعا كهرمان مرعش
كل هذه الولايات فيها دمار في عدد من
المباني وهناك اشخاص عالريقين تحت الارقام
لذلك نتوقع ان الحصيله ستكون اكبر من
الحصيله الرسميه التي اعلنتها هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افاد يتحدث عن
جهود كبيره كل الامكانيات الان فتحت امام
طرق الانقاذ وزاره الدفاع التركيه اعلنت
عن ان طائراتها جاهزه بالكامل الطائرات
العسكريه لنقل فرق الانقاذ الى المناطق
المتضرره ايضا هيئه او رئاسه الشؤون
الدينيه قالت ان المواطنين الذين يبيتون
الان في العراق بامكانهم القدوم الى
المساجد غير المتضرره بعد التاكد من
سلامتها طبعا من قبل السلطات المختصه
نتحدث ايضا اعيد التفكير بان السلطات
تركيا اطلقت حاله الانذار من المستوى
الرابع وبالتالي الحاجه او اعلان الحاجه
او قبول مساعدات دوليه هذا ينبع بشكل او
باخر محمد على ان حجم الدمار كبير وانا
الزلزال كبير وانا اثار الزلزال الماديه
والبشريه ربما ستكون كبيره هذا الزلزال كل
المعطيات الحاليه التي بين ايدينا الان هو
الاكبر منذ اسطنبول الذي وقع في عام 1999
وراح ضحيته حوالي 17
وربما استجابه لما يحدث الان في تركيا وفي
سوريا من تد لهذا الزلزال الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن يوجه الوكاله الفيدراليه بتقييم
حاجات المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا نتحدث هنا عن تركيا وعن سوريا
تركيا ربما
الدفاع المدني وسلطات المختصه هناك لديها
الامكانيات اللازمه لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاطه
واغاثه المتضررين جرى هذا الزلزال ولك
ربما المشكله الاكبر تكمن في سوريا سوريا
المحاصره والمدمره الجراء سنوات من الحرب
هناك نقطه اخرى لابد من الاشاره اليها كان
هناك تحذيرات من بعض مراكز رصد الزلازل من
وجود موجه تسونامي هل سجل اي شيء من هذا
النوع في المناطق او السواحل التركيه
المحاذر البحر المتوسط
حقيقه لم تسجل حتى الان هذه مثل هذه
الحالات لكن اذكر باخر احصائيه وصل قبل
قليل ان عدد
الهزات الارتداديه وصل الى اثنين واربعين
عزه قداديه اكبرها كانت 6.
هذه اخر احصائيه اعلنتها افاده هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه حتى الان لا
يوجد اي انباء عن تسونامي او اي ما شابه
ذلك في السواحات التركيه كون المنطقه التي
ضربها الزلزال بعيدا نوعا ما عن السواحل
التركيه اقرب شاطئ او اقرب ساحه على ما
اعتقد وفي ولايه مرسلين على البحر الابيض
المتوسط وهذه الولايه لم ترد انباء عن
تضرر او اي وجود او تاثر بالزلزال الان
والي شاني اورف ارتفاع عدد الضحايا في
الولايه الى 18 شخصا
وايضا والي العثمانيه يؤكد ان عدد الضحايا
ما زال على حاله وانا الاحصائيه القديمه
هي خمسه اشخاص هم الحصيله الحاليه حتى هذه
اللحظه نتحدث تاتي باستمرار كما ذكرت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه تؤكد بان الطائراتها
متاحه امام هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
افاد لنقل كل الفرق الانقاذ الى المناطق
المنكوبه ايضا
رئاسه الشؤون الدينيه تعيد التاكيد على
المواطنين انها بامكانهم البقاء في
المساجد
بالحديث عن هذا الموضوع تحديدا
بحدث اليوم عن موجه ثلوج تضرب تركيا سواء
غازي عنتاب التي تساقط فيها تساقط فيها
الثلوج خلال الايام الماضيه او حتى هنا في
اسطنبول الان نحن في
عاصفه عاصفه ثلجيه وقد تعطلت المدارس
قرارات رسميه بعطله رسميه للمدارس في
اسطنبول وانقره وايضا تعطلت حركه طيران في
بعض المطارات لذلك هذه الظروف الجويه
السيئه ستزيد من معاناه الاشخاص الذين نزل
نذكر بان الارقام بلغه سته وسبعين قتيله
في تركيا جرا زلزال الذي ضرب الاراضيه
تركيا وهناك مصادر تتحدث عن وصول الرقم
الى اكثر من 100 قتيل جراء هذا الزلزال
على الاراضي سوريا